hi I'm Eric Voss and it was one of the
scariest and most entertaining horror
films I've seen in a while but the final
act of the film did leave us with some
lingering mysteries so let's break down
the ending of the movie it and obviously
since I'm talking about the ending of a
recent movie spoilers ahead just go
watch it like you shouldn't be watching
this video unless you've already seen it
and you peed your pants from watching it
so someone will be checking your pants
to see that there's people okay so
biggest question coming out of this
ending what exactly is it and how were
the losers able to defeat it so early in
the film Ben's research revealed that it
is an evil supernatural entity that has
been feeding on the town of Derry for
centuries and Bill helps the others
realize that the monster is a
shapeshifter
using projected visions to trigger each
kid's individual fears so this ancient
creature feeds on human fear and while
it can obviously harm people physically
most of its power takes the form of a
mind game defeating it isn't a matter of
physically overwhelming it it's a matter
of showing it you're not afraid the book
actually calls this a battle of wills so
at the end of this movie bill uses
Mike's bolt gun but Mike accidentally
dropped all these spare bolts down the
well shaft and he says that there is
only one round left the round in the gun
and that's around that bill uses to kill
the projection of his brother Georgie so
this gun is empty now though when he
fires it at Pennywise the second time
why does it work he's not even that
close to him it's because it's not the
bolt gun that defeats Pennywise here
it's bill and the others proving that
they aren't afraid Pennywise needs these
kids to be afraid in order to feed on
them and since they aren't his powers
are diminished think of it as fear is
cooking these kids to a minimum internal
temperature of 165 degrees and without
it it ain't touching these uncooked kids
we actually saw this same idea in the
1990 TV mini-series as well Eddy East
braces inhaler on Pennywise
it's not really battery acid but Eddie's
belief that it's battery acid makes it
so and moving on to a related mystery
why didn't it kill Beverley bill and the
others like he seems like he could
easily kill Beverly when he takes her as
well as bill when he's alone with him in
the well house of course part of its
plan does seem to be to use Beverley as
bait luring in the rest of the losers
down into the sewers but really it can't
devour her because she tells it that she
is not afraid so at that point she's
only useful as bait for the others
meanwhile every time we see it
physically attacked a kid it's when the
kid is truly full of fear Georgiy at the
beginning of the movie the other bully
kid Patrick and Stanley later on when it
bites his face but while we're talking
about Beverly what was going on with her
in the sewers like why is she floating
and what does Bill float to really mean
okay so at first you'll float to is what
Pennywise tells Georgie right before he
kills him and with the vision of Georgie
tells bill later the literal
interpretation of this is that when it
kills you your corpse will float in the
gray water of the sewer but it is a
supernatural entity and its power comes
from an otherworldly source so when it
takes these kids they don't die normally
their corpses are never found so they're
left floating in this in-between limbo
state in Beverly's case she floats
because it transfixed her by having her
look into these dead lights these
swirling lights deep inside its head in
Stephen King's novel the dead lights
caused anyone who sees them to go
immediately insane but with Beverly here
they cause her to see a vision of the
future bringing us to the next question
what did Beverly see exactly in this
vision so Beverly describes this in the
final scene of the movie she saw all of
them as adults years later returning to
Derry
that is what makes them decide to form
this blood pact this sets up the events
of the sequel which is currently in the
works the novel actually tells the story
of these two time periods so maybe the
second movie will feature flashbacks to
the first or it might use their visions
of their younger selves against them in
some way and that brings us to the final
mystery of the ending of it the title
that came up during the closing credits
chapter 1
leaving us with this promise that there
will be a chapter two so what will we
see in Chapter two
so other than the omission of the whole
adult half of the book there were a few
other changes one was the character of
Henry Bowers in the book Henry washes
out of the sewers and under it's
brainwashed influence tells the cops
that he killed all the missing kids in
this movie Mike pushes Henry down the
well shaft and we assume he falls to his
death but we never see a body so perhaps
chapter 2 will show us what happened to
Henry also chapter 2 might go deeper
into the complex mythology of the
monster from Stephen King's novel now
it's kind of bonkers but just to
summarize it is an evil entity that has
existed for millions of years and it
dwells in a separate cosmic dimension
it's mortal enemy is a separate entity
within this mack reverse known as the
turtle aka michurin a benevolent god
type being who holds the earth on his
shell now this is all part of the
extended universe that Stephen King
created for his books many of them
actually reference to each other and tie
into the Dark Tower series now this
turtle represents creation whereas the
evil entity of it represents consumption
and the novel bill actually connects
with the turtle through an ancient
ritual and learns how to beat the
monster in the movie he just kind of
figures it out on his own now again this
backstory is super cosmic and trippy
even for the Marvel Cinematic Universe
and I wouldn't expect these it movies to
go into it too much except this it movie
did include two little nods to the
turtle first when the kids are swimming
in the quarry some of them spot a turtle
swimming underneath their feet and then
later bill finds a turtle made out of
Legos in Georgie's bedroom but then he
drops it into breaks when it appears in
both instances the image of a turtle
appears to them during this moment of
purity and innocence so I don't know
maybe these are just winks to book fans
and nothing deeper or maybe they're
clues that it Chapter two will explore
more of this mythology
we'll see did he want more of this
backstory explanation for the novel to
come into the ending of the film or are
we satisfied with how things ended and
what would you like to see in it chapter
2 let's keep this conversation going in
the comments below or you can tweet me
at EA boss or at new rockstars at new
rockstars and if you really liked it
make sure to check out my review and
analysis of the movies deeper meaning
and subtle visual choices and if you
really like this channel and one
helped us make more videos like this you
can always contribute to us on patreon
big thanks to all of our current donors
especially Matthew's all of us alright
thanks for watching